after another night of icy temperatures
in kiev
protesters sang the ukrainian national
anthem to keep their spirits up
the government said it would not use
violence against the demonstrators
and last night it kept its promise many
protesters have reinforced their
barricades
and they're defiant
we want our nation to be self-sufficient
and free
the people should be in control of the
government not the other way round
pressure from abroad has mounted since a
police raid on tuesday
the u.s has been mediating and is also
considering sanctions
top eu diplomat katherine ashton has
held talks with the ukrainian president
in recent days
back in brussels she expressed optimism
that ukraine would after all
join an eu trade agreement
look janukovich made it clear to me that
he intends to sign the association
agreement
but ashton didn't provide details she
said the ukrainian deputy prime minister
would hold talks thursday or friday in
brussels
those challenges which are real russia
has maintained the pressure on ukraine
in his annual state of the nation
address however president vladimir putin
was less outspoken
i hope that all political forces in
ukraine can reach a deal in the interest
of its people
and solve all the current problems putin
added that russia wasn't forcing ukraine
to do anything it didn't want to do
moscow is unlikely to let go of ukraine
without a fight
since it's a crucial economic and
strategic partner
meanwhile the demonstrators who have
refused to give ground in kiev
made their decision long ago they want
ukraine to turn away from russia and
embrace the european union